yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing blind face cream from Argentina
so looks like we got another King zinan
yep going for the main line here and I
haven't yet studied all that thoroughly
after same don't rely on a huge expert I
just wonder if I go b3 does he just play
a 4 here in this position I can't also
they can also start with this maybe this
probably doesn't matter all that much x5
is actually a rare move in such a
position usually they go h5 we'll see
had to play a free though okay maybe I
could have taken one at five that says
it's possible they will subscribe g5
winning a pizza so black activated his
bishop like that still question if this
is a a good way to claim my ideas now to
play before text ignite a four-night big
five which looks like a threat to me and
so he puts more pressure there c is it
take if able to make a tactical ring in
a key takes takes h6 is hanging and
stuff so i think this is still working
maybe I should have looked a little bit
more tower leave it don't want to fall
behind too much yeah now it's an issue
here no there is no issue for him you
just ignore that I mean everything as
five is hanging so this is not a problem
he says yeah maybe take sticks t2 is
hanging as well so light c4 here or I
can also take first take and play the 53
I wonder at is good actually Sally Sally
messy business and that's before you
might take from taking is the is the way
to to try to exploit that Bishop d3
[Music]
let's do it I actually wonder if 95 is
somewhat possible you should see form I
just let them into a book and their five
laying I just five you should see for
should rub 96 I can just take so why is
that move working help I don't get
anymore so okay I can I just take it I
cannot take on your phone to understand
what am I missing probably probably
nothing for a change in you one let an
English of 87 or Bishop g6
now that looks like a disaster actually
for black full flash disaster
Melissa would move on threatening both
to shoot g6 and h7 and yes so here I can
still maybe check not completely
convincing
yeah King f8 seems to still continue
this game let's go see a clear window
maybe you just cry scream be to him he
just put pursuing my queen isn't there a
way to finish this all I should have
looked at this now now i cannot even
play Bishop f5 Jesus what did i do here
queen bee one is really bad I mean I
could have just trade it for something
yeah I relaxed too early them I was
thinking I'm winning anyway but I don't
really don't it's not so easy
[Music]
I can can play this time or 84 Queen g6
yes but you can move the chain 2 h8 is
the thing now I don't have a clear win I
don't see it at least I can take I can
take so I ok it will feel that I can
take but i was thinking queen a1 no 93 I
saw this but it's not a clip not so
clear I'm not threatening all that much
and friendly Queen at six but that's
something that he can probably cover may
I Queen and what actually how does he
covered Quincy five maybe and do we want
to trade you a lot i don't i don't think
i want and there isn't so clear nice
night comes around and whatever don't
know look at six might be a threat if I
my king is a little bit safer like Age 3
look at six I can try that the five is
covered so cannot take them
[Music]
it looks annoying yeah and I think it
wins I a screwed that up royally at one
point check check black for sex only
time yeah I can't watch it this is
completely winning but I didn't do that
correctly for sure this seems fine any
went here and now i know i mean just
screwing it up somehow i mean i'm a
product he's got an open king and so on
and so forth and this is probably really
rubbish even immediately she did who
seems to seems to do something been
tagged he had a simple move Bishop f3
Wow nalysis totally it was just not
crossing my mind at all to put the
bishop back at sonia i mean if you see
well once you see the move you see that
white must be better i'm keeping all my
advantages and he doesn't have any
decent counterplay they don't have to
and now yeah so this oh wow you could
have taken why oh my god Mighty One will
be so insane I wanted sure such a more
yeah we're thinking this but he actually
just placed king age aid because my loop
only one is hanging and if i take here
she's heck meetings Wow
so Bishop n7 was a huge blunder could I
have done that to get the same position
no check because now it's got this one
while i was extremely lucky now no one
better i am a lot better be 64 k but i
think this was pretty okay i'm quite
happy that i have found does look at
six-thirty 8056 then I was winning oh my
god how's it was surprisingly difficult
I mean I just I just relaxed a bit too i
was just thinking okay like here things
are basically settled but this is a good
reply I mean okay Queenie to is the
engines suggestion or look-see would be
too that's not very intuitive Queenie to
is actually yeah once you see it as it
makes that makes a little sense but
still a tough game thanks for watching